well this week Bank of America announced
it will no longer lend money to
companies that manufacture what it calls
assault weapons for civilian use that
move comes in the wake of Citigroup's
announcement it won't work with
retailers unless they bar gun sales to
people under 21 news accounts describe
these as victories for gun control and
they are but they're not victories for
America even if you hate guns and you
hate gun owners even if you want to
repeal the Second Amendment entirely you
should not be celebrating this
development you should be worried
there's a threat to you and the country
and here's why Bank of America is the
second largest American bank by assets
what a nice people work there it's huge
it holds more than 10% of all bank
deposits in America the company is big
enough that if it aligned with other
companies and took direction from
progressive groups as it is in this case
it could make sweeping changes to
America without even a single vote being
cast this is a change it used to be the
political activist lobby lawmakers in
Congress when they wanted something
changed they gave money those donations
were recorded the rest of us could see
it happen that's happening less and less
now they Lobby big companies and the
lobbying is done in secret there's no
transparency at all you might not even
know it's happening
and yet it can affect your life
immensely as much as any federal law
today its gun makers you might be
celebrating that but what if tomorrow
it's someone you agree with or anyone
who holds ideas that our leaders find
threatening pro-life are you opposed to
immigration suspicious of Wall Street
corporate America isn't comfortable with
those views so suddenly I don't know you
can't get a car loan or a mortgage or
fill in the blank a version of this is
actually already happening in China on a
very large scale citizens there are
rated on the basis of their obedience to
prevailing orthodoxy those who disagree
are punished in the marketplace this is
significant because our corporate elites
love China it's a model for them there's
no messy democracy to contend with and
people get rich in China corporate power
is the same as political power
ideologues and companies work together
and ordinary people obey because they
have no choice suddenly America is
moving in that direction
it's ominous Bank of America oughta
stick to banking it does a good job at
that and it's
for everybody when they stay in their
Lane it's what see right is founder and
CEO of blueprint strategy and a gun
control supporter and he joins us
tonight it's one thanks for coming on
so thanks sucker for having me always a
pleasure thank you so I understand that
you agree with the aims of this
progressive groups apply pressure to
corporate America and people get in line
or they're punished I get that you like
the outcome but can you see that
democracy dies a little bit when this is
how we solve our political differences
why if you want to change gun laws
wouldn't you in full view of the rest of
the country go to Congress and make your
case but you're not doing that are you
well let me tell you what I agree with
what I agree with is what majority of
this country agree with and that is the
fact that we need to do something about
this issue of guns in this country to
prevent another mass shooting from
happening
I agree with 75% or somewhere north of
there agree with and look I commend my
ankle's I'm sorry I don't want to I just
want to be clear those numbers don't
mean anything there's something she okay
but nobody there's no national movement
to get Bank of America or Citibank to
punish people for violating liberal
orthodoxy on guns there just isn't this
is the result of lobbying from Quinn
Tucker Tucker this is not about the left
or the right this is about common sense
this is about common sense gun reform
measures look at Washington DC
dysfunctional City does not step up to
the plate and do what needs to be done
this country I commend corporations for
having a corporate responsibility to do
things in which democracy too long then
I get no I understand what you have to
break a few eggs to make whatever it
takes I want to take what you just said
and extend it into the future when
companies decide that I don't know pick
a group black lives matter has incited
riots and said racist things which it
has all of a sudden if you're affiliated
with black lives matter you like a
Facebook post by black lives matter you
can't get a car loan because why would
we abet this kind of crap how will you
feel about that
well I would feel keep in mind Tucker
there's been a period of history in this
country with corporations and
have denied and done similar things to
certain groups of people
yeah who live in this country so we've
learned to take Tucker I've learned to
take battles one fight at a time and
guess what you as a private citizen have
the right to not shop with not shop with
Bank of America every Mart I love this
let me give you a thought to consider
and I'm sure you've heard this him
before we can't look to government to
solve all of our problems therefore I
commend the private sector for stepping
up to clever of course we both know you
don't believe a word of it this is
purely transactional you get what you
want America to make me obey that's
totally cool with you but if it whipped
around into you and you'd be totally
against it wouldn't you chucko why can't
you agree with me that it takes it takes
the private sector and government to get
things then sometimes in this country
why can't you agree with that you get
these talking points were you an intern
for Paul Ryan at one point I mean I
guess what's so Orwellian about this is
common sense gun reform measures that
make sense and I commend a putter a
sentence that is straightforward and
actually means what it sounds like let's
take all the propaganda all the cans out
of this and just say what we mean what
you mean clearly is whatever we need to
do to make people obey including using
banks or whatever instrument we're happy
to do because the ends justify the means
if you just say that you know what I
will genuflect before you in gratitude
for your honesty will you just say that
Tucker bless your heart and I know you
want to put things in my mouth to make
something sound a certain way but that's
not what I'm saying all I'm saying is I
commend corporations like Bank of
America through the play and who are
willing to do what lawmakers in
Washington DC we believe very much you
in the Chinese government I can see that
thank you so much for joining us
Thank You Tucker